so
let's get started um so bpm and js
the thing is most of us already know
have an idea of what bpm is it's beats
per minute and
you know we know it's a generalized
tempo measurement for songs to see how
fast or slow it is but
if you really look around historically
it's been a very manual process you have
people
labeling the actual beats and uploading
profiles to databases to make this data
available to applications and
you know that's just not ideal in a
world where things are changing so
quickly and we want this data available
readily so i wanted to look into number
one how to
make this an automatic detection process
and second of all
you know just trying to bring it into
the javascript world so that we can all
use it
first things just a little bit about
myself right now i'm working at twitter
in the new york office as a software
engineer on the web team
my name is janessa det if you didn't
catch that from the first slide
and the program and previously from that
i
come from the background of computer
graphics and vision and then before that
a lot of bioengineering where i mostly
hated the bio and mostly liked the
engineering so
um so what are we really talking about
here in terms of
what's behind automatic protection of
bpm well
in research they call it onset detection
so if you look at the signal that i have
here
what we have is we're looking for this
thing we're looking for when the beat
happens there's a really
sharp signal change and we want to see
where that is to know where beats are
happening
so what this is fundamental to is like a
million different fields
and uh that includes sonar speech ekgs
movement detection
and you know some things maybe like iron
man
i think i secretly wanted to put him in
my slides too so but
um but seriously sort of so discover ran
an interesting article about becoming
iron man how close is research to really
making these suits that you can control
you know with your nerves if you're into
the comic books he installs stuff into
his body to interface
and um you know that involves things
like eeg or electro and cephalography
which you're detecting onsets for the
nerve signals and
you do a lot of analysis after that but
you get the point this is a very
fundamental sort of applicable thing not
just to music but a lot of things
but since i'm a music nerd personally i
like to
think of it this is a much more
interesting application that i want to
look at which is uh
automatic transcription of music the
first step is
you know detecting your beats of course
but there's also things like
instrument identification instrument
isolation pitch projection dynamics
all things that i plan to hopefully in
the future look into as well
and by reading lots of research papers
and stuff so
so why did i want to bring it into the
browser like you know there's c
implementations and research being
passed around of this stuff
well the biggest thing is i find
research papers in this whole academic
research area
to be so niche and closed and you know
entwined in the politics and people
never really look at research papers i
wanted to bring
that sort of engineering and make it
accessible and shareable and
cross-platform and make it easy for all
of us here to just use and play with
and the other thing that enables this is
that you know the browser
javascript is seriously fast now like
it's no joke
like this article that ran earlier
and that's really just
it's just helping us to do things that
are really computationally heavy without
having to worry about delays and lag
time as much
and with things like you know we just
saw so much going on with webgl
and web audio and digital signals
processing is really enabled in the
browser now it's pushing that forward we
can do a lot of these computational
things which
you know makes the browsers really
powerful you can do so much awesome
stuff
so the caveat of course is you know all
these things are great but they only
work in the latest and greatest canary
beta you know
new shiny builds of uh um i'm sorry
about that
um i meant chrome uh firefox
safari and opera and that was a little
bit mean because ie really is coming
along with that but
um also why in the browser well you know
when i was thinking about doing this
honestly this was the biggest reason i
think javascript is fun i think this
stuff is fun and it would be cool to
play with and i think that's the best
reason to start working on something
and another thing to note is that the
browser is really diverse now you know
it's not the 90s anymore for
document display where the most
interesting thing i could find was you
know
unlimited gifs of sailor moon or gifs or
whatever
and more importantly the community is
really diverse like we've seen such a
great subset here of the javascript
community everyone comes from such
different backgrounds from art
backgrounds
music backgrounds you know all sorts of
engineering and
because of that we're really pushing the
use cases of the browser and what we can
do with it and what it's becoming
enabled for
um you know we're influencing it by
making people who are on the standards
community think about the different
things that we want to do with it
besides
you know displaying all the animated
gifs you could possibly find on the
internet
um my personal mission in terms of this
little diversity thing is
i come up from an engineering background
from my undergrad
i'm a huge music nerd and you know now
i'm doing full-fledged computer science
web development
so i like to put this in my bio um
finding ways to read engineering
research music and art with a trusty
steed of javascript that's javascript
not horse js
to make the magical unicorns of my
imagination a reality so
i found an image that sort of like
captured my mental image
i wanted to share with you so just in
case you didn't know this
this is the magical unicorn i'm going
for breathing fire like epic
eyes and that's me that's the cat riding
the
epic magical unicorn and there's a
little neon cat in the back
set i thought that was like really
awesome but you know this is like living
the dream like i
you know i'm gonna take engineering and
smash it with art and music and
javascript and it's gonna like look
awesome but so far because things are
coming along
a lot of my projects end up looking like
that you know what is he saying there
i must eat more rainbows like it's it's
they're a little bit lumpy and awkward
right now but we're getting there you
know
and it's still a lot of fun you still
have a unicorn it's just you know in
kind of you know awkward and derping
but anyways let's jump in let's breed
some unicorns
um so this is a big question right how
do we do onset detection like what is
this
um first i want to take a quick step
back and
think about you know bpm we think about
it because djs are like all popular now
and you know bpm it's like that you know
thump thump that you hear on the bottom
but
it can mean a lot of things it's really
tied to human psychology and it's
can be anything from percussive beats
which is what we think of
it could also be pitching notes you know
you have like a flute piece from the
classical
music era and it's like you don't have a
drum in the back like you know and sing
you know like in a club so
um on sets this is just a little bit of
research terminology they like to
categorize it into a lot of different
names because it is more complex than
just detecting where the drums are
so there's you know pitched or not
pitched percussive and more commonly now
it's complex plex mixed which is
basically
like everything else because they can't
label everything um
some quick sort of just scoping a lot of
times bpms are associated with genres
these days for
example you know drum and bass they like
to say it's like 160 to 180 and etcetera
etcetera and you know if we're talking
about classical music
if you have a background did it um i did
piano for 14 years so
this adagio for example 66 to 76
bpm it's not just this new dj thing like
matching bpms in the cloud you know so
um detection method so how do we do this
and how did i learn how to do this well
i read a lot of research papers and i'm
not going to read this out to you right
now
but um i think this part was actually a
lot of fun
and interesting understanding some
esoteric language so i'll break it down
into something sort of bite-sized for
this talk
um so first what we're doing there's
some
general steps we're doing an sdft short
time fourier transform
which basically the purpose of it is to
prep the signal for detection functions
um then we do the detection function
what these are are
functions that are meant to selectively
maximize for onset properties that we're
looking for
and turn them into strong signals we can
pick out
in peak picking which after you have
those highlighted onset
times you can pick out those times from
the signal that you've now got all like
processed
and from there it's you know home free
you calculate the bpm
so i'm not going to go too much into the
mathematical detail of things but i do
want to show you
a high-level view of what this looks
like just so you have an idea of what
i've tried to stuff into javascript
sdft does a number of steps it's not
just a fourier transform it does window
slicing
slicing the signal into overlapping
windows often for
this application as small as 50
milliseconds 80 milliseconds
and then you apply hamming window to
trim off the edges of
bad stuff basically just continuities
and normalization normalizing the
magnitude
and zero padding because it needs to be
a power of two to do an fft on it
and it clarifies the signal you can get
into that if you want on your own
and then finally you do your fft and get
a bunch of complex numbers in a matrix
so detection functions what these look
like i'm going to
go over the ones that were frequency
based because they were
more robust out of some of the ones i
looked at and also these
seem to be the ones that are more
prevalent more robust got recognition
high frequency content and spectral
difference i stuck the math in there if
they're math and engineering nerds and
want to like dig into the summations
but these two maximize on
energy which you know tends to be those
percussive beats
phase deviation is more sensitive to
things like pitch
and euclidean distance tries to smash
these two things together into something
a little bit more balanced
so you know we're looking for that onset
there trying to highlight it
peak picking um there's a few it's not
um
as simple as you would think be just
because these signals are noisy and
you're doing processing on them they're
still going to be noisy
so you're building an adaptive threshold
um which
you'll kind of see the visualizations
later that i have for this
and by applying that threshold we try to
cut out the noise and actually pick out
where the onsets are
so initial peak finding you threshold
them out and refractory period is
another way of filtering
where you say oh there's no way there
can be a beat between
this time this time because it's too
short and it's probably noise because
they're right next to each other so
this helps to cut out some of those
noisy signals if you pick some of your
windows wrong
and not to bore you too much with the
nitty-gritty details of this but peak
times
this is a trivial example but say i have
a bunch of peak times
so it's really simple from here it's
about 0.5 across the way i average it
and there's a beat every half second and
that's about 120 bpm oh you missed the
happy unicorn i press next
well i think the unicorn i had high
hopes for my unicorn
how do we do it in javascript um i'm
going to go over some of the fun things
i ran into
they're kind of fun oh but before that i
tried to
think of some interesting things i could
do with this you know initial
implementation
and i found one song that i particularly
like
if you don't listen to discovery they're
fantastic you should look them up but so
insane by discovery
they do an interesting thing where in um
two in two spots in the song they kind
of dip it down into a lower bpm and like
slow it down and make it like all
you know groovy and um i wanted to see
if i could maybe pick that up by slicing
it into 10 second signals or
10 second windows of signals and pushing
it through and seeing if i could see a
modulation
i assigned some colors to it
where darker means a slower bpm
and lighter means a lighter a higher bpm
and i found that these two patches um
you know they're 10 second signals so
it's still pretty
granular but it actually picked up
pretty closely to the time stamps on the
bottom
where these were happening so i was
really excited about that i wanted to
show you
so tools that i use that were really
helpful just being like how do i bring
this
research picture and put it into
javascript and
dsp.js was really helpful i didn't have
to write my own fft algorithm it's been
done
it's been out there and people have been
using it i used it also for my windowing
function so that was super helpful
there's a node actually no there wasn't
an npm version i've had to do some
interesting wrapping of the stuff only
that i needed
and taking it out but web audio
does great things like how i use it in
its most rudimentary form is you take a
signal
you throw the file at web audio and it
will spit out a sample rate and a
float32 array for me to work with which
is great
complex arithmetic you do have to do
complex math with this
so i found a handy npm module so that i
didn't have to write that too because
that would just be
silly to reinvent the wheel and a lot of
the other stuff i just had to kind of
write a lot of math and stick it in a
lot of loops so
for that browser if i was a huge help
for me just being able to keep my code
organized insane so i could see what was
going on and see how things were
connecting
clearer thing about how it actually
connected together bpm that was my like
main driver module
web audio as i said feeds the signal and
information in
and these were the three things i went
over before so
i separated them out according to what i
saw and
a lot of the math was happening there so
connecting up all of those things there
and detection i had the four detection
functions so
this is much easier to you know browser
i just
really like it and source maps are
awesome so
um so interesting challenges that i ran
into this is a little anecdotal i
suppose
um i've never really had to work with
float32 arrays before
this so that was interesting because i
realized you know you can't just add
zeros onto the end you have to like
slice it and like copy the array buffer
and stick it in a thing that's bigger
so that was interesting to learn about
and i mean
that's the best thing if you're learning
when you're building new projects so it
was fun
but compatibility you know web audio is
enabled right now in chrome and now
also in beta versions of everything else
which is great but
that's something that you kind of have
to be
realistic about and then complex
arithmetic and matrices like you know
coming from engineering where like
matlab does everything for you they have
like a function due to the most complex
things and matrices and just spits out
answers like
javascript's not built for that so i had
a lot of like verbose like pushing stuff
around like beating it into like
javascript form
to make it really like pop out the
complex stuff that i needed
um and the biggest thing was just
figuring out how not to break chrome i
have an optimization slide later
where i know i haven't addressed a lot
of optimizations things that i wanted to
do but didn't quite get to
so i'm aware but it was really
interesting
so there was a lot of this where i
actually put a debug statement in a
place that
i probably shouldn't have put a debug
statement but it was late at night these
are those complex objects from that
library
and it was like four windows in and it
was like
and you know i tweeted it out of
frustration of course my snarky
co-workers are like well look look
you're doing something complex well
there's your problem like
thanks it's like four in the morning not
encouraging but like uh
literally it would get to the point
where you know chrome started showing me
like measurement rulers randomly and
they would get like stuck
it'd be like by the way your window is
blah blah i'm like i've never seen this
before i have what did i do to it like
you know my poor chrome is like crying
at me and like
after a while like yeah i would hit
localhost 3000 and literally it would
just
meet a crash be like no i know what you
do with this dress like you can't do
this anymore to me and just stop
but um that was interesting and you know
looking at these arrays there's a lot of
dot dots behind this tweet where it's
like thousands of
you know indices that i was kind of
scraping through and
you know you make mistakes doing like
math.pal late at night doing math.pow
number two instead of two number
and etc so i was getting a lot of these
like
and when you're you know seeing a lot of
these late at night in my head i was
like no
no no no no i was like god i'm going
crazy
like someone saved me from the nands um
so
these were some interesting nights me
and
you know chrome happy together in batman
anyways enough of that you get the point
um
all right so here's where i'm gonna kind
of i stuck um a lot of little plotter
things in there to help debug and i
think it really illustrates
what's going on in the signal and to see
you know all the math stuff that i did
before in action so i thought that would
be helpful
to kind of show my code working and
crunching these numbers and shaping them
so this is what the original signal
something like this
would look like it's just plotting the
signal
hamming window trimming off the edges as
i said um
then the normalization the numbers are
like tiny but there's like one at the
top of that
and zero padding um
as much as you want and then ffts it you
know you saw in the previous screenshots
just complex complete complex they're
complex numbers um this might be a
little bit small but
there are actually not that many lines
of code it was just a little bit of
wrangling working with float32 arrays as
i said you know padding the signals not
just like push bunch of zeros at the end
it's like no there's like an array
buffer and then a view on top
so um things like that fft this would
have been so much longer if i didn't
have dsp so
you know god bless dsp.js um
same here for the detection functions
i'm just going to bring them all out
here so these are the four that i
covered before kept the math there
they're actually not that bad you know
once you learn how to read
mathematical and you know discrete
notation like
you could do so much with it so maybe
i'm echoing other people but like don't
be afraid of this stuff it's
it's just a couple lines of code you
know
not bad unicorns still looking pretty
good i thought
peak picking um so this is what it looks
like
after i've applied a detection function
i've done the euclidean distance one
here
um so you see that you have some like
strong peaks going up here
and that's detecting where those onsets
are happening and it's really like
spiking the signal up there so that you
can pick this out afterwards
here is the median filter step this is
part of the thresholding what it's doing
is
it's smoothing over the signal according
to a window size that you can kind of
filter out a lot of that noise that's
going on
that's just interrupting like seeing
clear peaks like that
so after it's filtered it's a lot
clearer it's flat it's flat like that
and you basically choose out the peaks
and et cetera et cetera and you have an
array of times and
like i showed before you take those and
what i do is i take the gaps
average them and do a little bit of math
and you have a
bpm for your sample
so here's my optimization and
performance slide how not to break
chrome i know there are ways and i just
haven't
quite delved into it yet but i'm excited
too soon because i want to
fix a couple things but web workers i
think are just ripe for this sort of
thing
um especially for the short time for a
transform
step where i have like a gazillion 50
millisecond windows i'm doing the exact
same thing to every single one of them
so um you know pass them into a web
worker um
as far as i know i know there's like an
exception for typed arrays as well where
you don't have to serialize and
deserialize it which just slows
everything down
and i'm using typed array so if i can
just pass that through
process all the crap and pass it back
like that will be a huge
performance um gain for me um
most music songs don't change in tempo
or bpm
so if i slice well selected windows i
don't have to process like a 10 minute
song
all at once like you know take it one
from the beginning middle and end
like i think i could basically figure it
out and that would
save just a ton of computation um
oh i have a third point that didn't show
up but it's basically
about um you know asm.js you know uh
and lljs it's perfect for this and i've
just started learning about it so
i might go back and like rewrite the
whole thing in ll and see what happens
so
we'll see but i thought this was
interesting so i tried out a matlab
implementation and matlab is like you
know the engineering dream
it does all the things with matrices all
at once for me you know median filter
like i wrote a median filter that one
it's like
median one signal window size it's like
one line
i'm like wow i wish i could do that in
javascript i guess we'll have to make it
so people can do it in javascript
but it was it was cool because um you
know i was testing with signals
on both of them and they actually take
about the same time it's not like matlab
is like
exponentially faster like i thought it
would be um i think a 10 second signal i
tried it was like an
uncompressed wave or something it took a
couple seconds in the browser
it's not bad matlab was about the same
you know it's like busy busy busy and it
spit out some stuff
so i was really encouraged by that you
know like go gs
love it and you know the dream here is
if i can make it fast enough like
all of this processing stuff with like
heavy computation it's always been like
something i post back and it generates
and generates it's like it's been a
couple hours can i fetch it yet like
there's a queue
can't fetch it yet but if we could do
this like all the client side and just
like
process almost real time i think that
would be super powerful just for
um you know anything you think of to do
this with oh there it is
azam and scriptum ljs if you were here
for brendan's talk which was epic
you know about all that
all right so there are some weaknesses
that i need to be realistic about and
these come straight from the research on
onset detection
you might have heard me mentioning
things like the median filter window
time you know the window
slicing could be 50 milliseconds or 80
milliseconds and
the thing is if you use those wrong like
you just make really giant windows or
you filter out that thing so it's so
smooth like you
eliminate all the onsets like you are
going to break this like it will give
you crazy numbers that
make you you know zero sense so um
that's just something to be aware of and
something that you know i still need to
test different parameters for different
detection functions to see
kind of where i can apply them and where
i can't and
so um also pre then this feeds into that
prior knowledge is often helpful to
selecting the right detection functions
like i said
some of them are pitch based so if you
have like a flute piece like the
percussive one is probably not going to
do that well on that but
you know phase deviation might and
there's
still a lot going on in research so
there's lots of reading to do
and just more things to look into
so future work just on the more general
side besides wanting to make it faster
is this is really only scratching the
surface of research
like i read a couple of papers found
some good summary papers
that summarize a lot of things going on
in the fields but there's so many more
detection functions that people are
developing every day like
this is their full-time job their phds
like underfed underpaid and
this is what they do all day in the lab
and you know i almost went into research
and i'm glad i didn't because i don't
have the personality for that but
god bless all the people who do like
this is crazy awesome stuff
and um as i mentioned previously for
different applications
you know onset detection exists it's
just forced signals so
really the only difference is yanking
out the detection functions i'm using
for music and sticking other ones in
and maybe other things i just haven't
read up on you know onset detection for
nerve signals and stuff like that
um so grading time so how did i do
was my javascript music engineering you
know
stuck together and taped with scotch
tape unicorn beautiful
well it's a little bit forced like i
have to admit like it's
i felt like i was like sticking you know
like because
engineering is a cute pug and into like
a javascript horse suit and it grew a
horn and some like fuzz
like it was it was okay like there's a
lot of things i can do better hopefully
like
clean it up you know put more skin on it
and it's like it'll be good
like we're really getting in there with
the browser um
the web is changing aggressively and
you know just as a quick example i was
just searching around npm for stuff to
use
and just to see what i could find when
you know very like basic
engineering sort of keywords dsp digital
signals processing fft which is the
fast fourier transform filters a little
less there but
um there's a lot of stuff out there for
free
that people are using every day
downloading maintaining you know like
this is
really awesome stuff like it's available
for us to play with and use and improve
upon and
contribute to um in godless npm because
i just
did a search and i found everything i
needed so
um and things like you know web audio
and
you know the w3c really pushing forward
on a lot of these uh really powerful
tools and
you know dspjs was like written forever
ago but glad i didn't have to do it
someone else did so
um and it's a lot about you know
rethinking web engineering it's like
i thought that when i left biomedical
engineering because i hated bio it's
like oh god i like learned all of this
electrical engineering stuff for nothing
like what am i gonna do but
you know to you know yesterday i built a
robot with like a breadboard like the
old days
and like you know now i get to use this
stuff in the web like
you know i didn't have to leave all that
behind so
what does it mean to be a web engineer
these days how about more engineering
like you can bring
all these things that you've learned or
if you want to learn like there's stuff
out there
to learn and you know we're all smart
people that's why we're here so
how about more engineering um this kind
of stuff like vendor prefixes is not the
final frontier anymore i know a lot of
people you know friends in new york who
have come over
from finance like completely different
fields having no idea and they're like
oh my god oh my god like look i found
like css transitions and i'm like that's
really nice
um now let me show you something on npm
that's really fun to play with that you
should play with like
that whole connect talk earlier like
they would have so much fun with that
like
you know these are cool and they're
important but like it's not the final
frontier like there is things beyond the
vendor prefix cacti and it's
thorny in the vendor prefix cacti but
that's another
topic um
i think it's just really important and i
mean now at
toward you know towards the end of this
conference i feel like this is not even
necessary to say anymore but
you know there have been so many diverse
talks just you know today even on all
the other days and it's really
important for us i think to embrace
diversity like
i think that this field is young enough
like you know web engineering and
javascript that
a lot of the people that i've met here
are really diverse they come from
engineering backgrounds art history
backgrounds music
you know like fine arts anything you can
think of they've done it and
i think because we're such an open
community like that's what we're known
for
we really need to embrace that and bring
it together and collaborate on all of
our different talents you know knowledge
really builds upon itself and combining
these fields generates a lot of powerful
tools like
you know you don't have to figure out
everything yourself like your peers have
done this like
you know like raquel she worked on
robots for years and years like she can
answer
all of your questions just ask you know
um
and you know just thinking outside of
the box like i said before like you know
i do web engineering at work all the
time
every day but in my free time you know i
want to do something different but
it's still things that i know the web
and other things but it's really
exciting and
a lot more fun i think for my free time
to just think outside the box so
you know breed on unicorns
and that's all i've got and i just want
to say again like
i really look forward to seeing all the
diversity that you can bring to web
engineering and you know show me
what you want to do and what you can do
and
i think we'll all be better for it so
yeah that's it thanks
you